After puberty, pubic hair begins to
surround our external genitalia. But with
hair removal and grooming becoming a
popular personal practice, is it really
the best idea to shave or wax down there
or is a full bush the way to go?
Humans lost most of their thick body hair
around seventy thousand to one hundred
and twenty thousand years after the last
ice age, but despite becoming mostly bare,
being retained plentiful hair in our
armpits and crotches becoming the only
mammalian species in the world to have
long course pubic hair. Researchers
hypothesize that pubic hairs after
puberty as a visual signal to potential
partners that one is ready to mate, while
the bushes itself act as protection from
friction during sexual intercourse.
Another theory involves sweat. Humans have
two types of sweat glands, one type
secretes mostly water and salt producing
no odor, while the other apocrine glands
are found specifically in the armpit and
the pubic areas and using the pubic hair
follicles secrete fluids rich in
proteins, lipids,  and pheromones. When bacteria on the
skin breakdown these molecules, you get
body odor. We may have evolved to retain
these hairs to trap pheromones to be
wanted towards potential mates. This is
further supported by the fact that women
release different pheromones during
ovulation signaling fertility in order
to become more attractive to others. But
a study of over 1,000 students in America
found that 96% of females and 87%
of males had either partially or completely
removed pubic hair within the past month.
As pubic hair its course, the regrowth
after any type of grooming can be
irritating to the skin. In fact 75% of
people sorting out their pubes have
experienced genital itching, and 40% have
experienced a rash of some sort.
Shaving and waxing can create here that
grows inward instead about to the
surfers resulting in red and inflamed
raised bumps. Interestingly, the incidents
of pubic lice has actually decreased due
to shaving and waxing.
However these practices can also create
microscopic abrasions on the skin, which
can become infected and even transmit a
myriad of sexually transmitted diseases.
It has been theorized that pubic hair
removal also correlates directly with
the rise of gonorrhea, chlamydia and HPV
infections. Even with infections put
aside, the most common genital injuries
reported in American emergency rooms are
a direct consequence of pubic hair
removal. At the end of the day, no matter
what grooming trends are currently
popular, there's no harm in growing that
bush the way that nature intended.
Before you go, we want to send a huge
thank you to thought cafe for animating this episode for us. They have a
fantastic channel but you should check
out. Its super creative and informative.
Be sure to check them out and subscribe
to  their channel for more fun and
educational content. Thanks for watching.